تبادلت روسيا واوكرانيا الاتهامات
بالمسؤوليه عن تفجير سد مدينه نوفاكاخوفكا
الواقعه بخيرسون جنوبيه اوكرانيا كان ذاك
خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات
باحثيات وتفجير سد كخوفكا وما مقاصد
المسؤول عن تفجيره في هذا التوقيت والى
ماذا يؤشر هذا المستوى من التصعيد بين
الجانبين وهل ينذر بدخول المواجهات مرحله
جديده من الصراع وما هي فرص خفض التصعيد
في ظل الحراك الدولي ودعوه مجلس الامن
للانعقاد
فنيا وبناء على تصميم السد وانا بحكم
خبرتي كظابط هندسه اقول احتماليه التفجير
بالصواريخ او المدفعيه لا اقول معدومه
ولكنها ضعيفه جدا هذا السد حتى يفجر يجب
ان يتم استخدام ما يطلق عليه بالحشوات
الغاطسه اللاصقه وتقاس بالعطنان من
المتفجرات العجينيه ار دي اكس او ما
يماثلها من المتفجرات الشرقيه يتوضا بنظام
هندسي محدد على ارتفاع معين من سطح الارض
وعلى عمق معين في المياه وتفجر في لحظه
واحده وعن بعد الان من الذي ايسر له ان
ينفذها الجانب الروسي هل يعني ذلك ان
الجانب الاوكراني لا يستطيع اقول يستطيع
من خلال الضفادع
المدربه ولكن يفترض بان هذا الجسر محمي
يبقى الاحتمال الاول والاكثر توفرا وحظوظا
في التمثيل سواء في الاستفاده او القدره
الجانب الروسي هكذا اقرا ما لم يصلح عكس
كلامي تعلمون ان اوكرانيا لم تبدا قصف سد
اليوم فقط السد كان في حالات حرجه واذكر
ان قبل نصف السنه عندما كانت خرسون تحت
السيطره الروسيه كان هناك صواريخ هايبر
ضربت مدخل السد وهذه صواريخ لا يمكن ان
يخلط بينها وبين الصواريخ الروسيه نحن
الان سمعنا وجهه النظر الروسيه لما حدث
ومن جديد اعتقد ان روسيا تحاول ان تكذب
للعالم كله اليوم من المستحيل ان نخفي
الحقيقه وفي الايام القريبه سوف يكون هناك
الكثير من
الحقائق والدلائل على ان روسيا هي من قامت
بهذا وان اوكرانيا ما كانت لتملك الوسائل
التكنولوجيه لتدمر هذه المنشاه اما سؤالك
عن مصلحه روسيا ليس لدي اي رد لانه فعلا
ليس هناك اي مصلحه لروسيا من هذا الرد
الوحيد الذي يبقى عندي هو ان المصلحه هي
محاوله الضرر بالنظام الاوكراني فقط
ان هذه الكارثه التي تعتبر غير مسبوقه في
التاريخ المعاصر لذلك اوكرانيا الان مضطره
لتحويل مصادرها الى انقاذ المواطنين وسوف
يكون هناك مشكله في تامين المياه العذبه
للمدن الساقطه على اضفه نهر الدبر عدا عن
المشاكل البيئيه
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا لم تبدا الهجمات العكسيه بعد ما
يحصل هي عمليه تشكيليه وهذا يعني ان
اوكرانيا تحدد المناطق التي سوف يكون فيها
الضربات الاساسيه لان الهجمات العكسيه قد
بدات فعلا ولكنها دون اي نجاح جميع
الهجمات العكسيه الاوكرانيه فشلت حتى
محاولتهم اجتياح الحدود الروسيه كما
تعلمين في بلغراد يعني الان ازدادت الامور
تعقيدا بالنسبه للجانب الاوكراني لانه
عليه ان يعيد تقييم الواقع الجديد ومدى
تاثيره على الخطه الهجوم التي كانت يتم
الاعداد لها منذ اشهر والان حدث منعطف
كبير جدا عليهم اعاده تقييم الوضع على
المستوى الاستراتيجي والعمليات والتكتيكي
ليس لدى اوكرانيا اي مخرج اخر الا
الاستمار في المعارك لانها اذا وضعت
سلاحها فهذا سيعني تجميد للمعارك وحسب
وهذا سيشكل امكانيه لروسيا حتى يتحضروا
لمرحله جديده من العدوان لذلك اوكرانيا
مصره تقوم بهزيمه روسيا هجيم هزيمه نهائيه
على ارض المعركه
وروسيا يجب ان تفشل وتهزم في اغلب جبهات
المعركه من الواضح ان الحديث الان ليس عن
السلام خاصه من الطرف الاوكراني وليس من
الواضح من اين سيبدا الاوكرانيين هجماتهم
لانهم لا يملكون اي قدرات لذلك من وجهه
نظري